en el último vídeo vimos un sistema que
podía trabajar al expandirse verdad y en
esa situación que dibujé teníamos la
situación donde el techo era movedizo
verdad teníamos un pistón que como
entonces en todos los vídeos que hemos
hecho teníamos encima un montón de
canicas movíamos uno y entonces la
presión del sistema si suponemos que
eran cambios tan pequeños podíamos
suponer que era constante entonces
avienta el pistón hacia arriba generando
cierta fuerza y entonces esta fuerza era
la multiplicación de la presión por el
área verdad entonces aplicamos esto y
cuando multiplicamos por una distancia
de la distancia que se mueve el pistón
entonces teníamos el trabajo de
expansión dado por la presión por el
área por el la altura la x que se movió
el pistón y que eso nos daba la presión
bueno el área por la distancia en
realidad era un volumen verdad un
desplaza desplazamiento en el volumen
por lo tanto el trabajo es igual a la
presión por el cambio en el volumen en
este caso escribí la fórmula de la
energía interna como el calor menos el
trabajo verdad menos porque estamos
haciendo un trabajo el sistema está
haciendo un trabajo y en esa situación
esto es igual al calor menos la presión
por el cambio en el volumen y recordemos
que este es un proceso cuasi estático y
que estamos haciendo incrementos muy muy
pequeños estamos suponiendo que este son
cambio en el volumen pequeño y que la
presión es más o menos constante
mientras hacemos esto y por supuesto
este era un cambio muy grande de volumen
verdad esto ocurría si quitamos una
canica pero bueno si eso es muy grande
podemos
quitaron una canica un poco más chiquita
o un granito digamos y así estamos
pensando en incrementos muy muy muy
pequeños
así la presión sería constante a lo
largo de esos cambios y podríamos hacer
estas operaciones que vimos entonces
vamos a ver qué ocurre con los diagramas
de presión volumen todo lo que hemos
visto en este tipo de diagramas es para
ayudarnos a explicar la diferencia entre
procesos cuasi estáticos o cuando son
macro estados bien definidos verdad pero
déjenme hacer ahora algo más útil y esto
les va a dar una idea de cómo pensar en
el estudio de la termodinámica y por qué
la gente ama mucho esto entonces como
dije anteriormente tenemos esta lata con
con un gas y las canicas sobre un pistón
y podríamos definir esto en términos de
sus macro estados como el volumen y la
temperatura también puedo describir su
energía interna y déjenme dibujar esto
aquí digamos que aquí está el estado
número 1 de aquí
ok y después digamos que empezamos a
quitar granitos y vamos quitando un
granito de uno en uno y para no entrar
en un estado de flujo verdad estamos
haciendo un proceso cuasi estático y
para nuestros fines estamos pensando que
es cuasi estático y que se mantiene en
el equilibrio aunque quizás en distintos
estados verdad si esto no fuera un
proceso casi estático entonces
tendríamos flujo y no queremos eso
queremos definirlo bien entonces estamos
cerca de un proceso cuasi estático
digamos no hay un proceso cuasi estático
como tal pero al menos teóricamente si
entonces en el último vídeo le dijimos
que podíamos movernos desde este punto 1
vamos quitando granitos y entonces vamos
haciendo una trayectoria suponiendo otra
vez que es un proceso casi estático una
trayectoria que conecta el estado 1
con el estado 2 entonces aquí está
nuestra nuestra trayectoria que llega al
estado 2 verdad déjenme dibujar esto
entonces el estado 2 se verá algo así
déjenme dibujarlo rápidamente digamos
que este es nuestro contenedor nuestro
pistón y sólo nos queda un granito en el
techo y por supuesto tenemos un buen de
gas aquí ok
déjenme escribir esto este es el estado
2 y ahora el estado 1
el estado uno era algo así verdad
teníamos un pistón un montón de granitos
un montón de piedritas ahí encima y
también teníamos un menor volumen verdad
así que el gas estaba rebotando mucho
más fuerte en las paredes de este de
este contenedor y teníamos mayor presión
verdad verdad entonces la presión era
mayor era muy alta y el volumen bajo y
en el estado 2 okay digamos y aquí está
la presión y aquí está el volumen
entonces teníamos en la situación 2
teníamos una menor presión y un mayor
volumen verdad todo esto estaba en en
distintos equilibrios el equilibrio se
iba moviendo pero es esto es porque es
un proceso casi estático verdad entonces
aquí teníamos una presión más baja y un
volumen mayor verdad el volumen más alto
y puedes seguir empujando un poquito el
pistón este y moviendo las cosas de esta
forma de tal suerte que los macro
estados estén bien definidos ahora
nuestra presión
este es más baja porque las partículas
cada vez que rebotan en alguna pared
tienen mayor espacio para moverse verdad
entonces esta trayectoria describe el
proceso que experimenta el el sistema
que era cuasi estático y todo está
definido en cualquier punto ahora
decimos que el trabajo hecho por el
sistema es la presión por el cambio en
el volumen como eso se relaciona aquí
entonces el cambio en el volumen digamos
es esta distancia en el eje x ok este es
un cambio en el volumen y empezamos en
este volumen
ok quitamos una canica y empieza y
llegamos a este volumen como hicimos
estos pequeños incrementos ok cerca del
equilibrio podríamos digamos que en este
periodo de tiempo decir que es constante
la presión entonces como hicimos este
trabajo
y la presión por el volumen que es
básicamente el área de este rectángulo
verdad
y para todos aquellos que ya han estado
viendo los vídeos de cálculo a lo mejor
ya parece que están viendo algo muy
familiar verdad a lo mejor y están
poniendo hasta los ojos en blanco de la
emoción ahora sí pensamos que tenemos
una nueva presión de este lado en este
pequeño incremento también de volumen
tenemos el área
en el área de este rectángulo verdad
otra vez que es el cambio del volumen
por la presión
y si mantenemos haciendo esto la
cantidad de trabajo
es esencialmente el área de todos estos
rectángulos ok
al ir removiendo cada granito de cada
granito verdad y bueno esto a lo mejor
no es exactamente verdad la suma de las
áreas de los rectángulos pero se va
apareciendo a la curva de la al área
debajo de esta curva bueno si a lo mejor
queremos refinar esto podemos pensar en
cambios de volumen mucho más pequeños y
eso nos da que la presión en la presión
por el cambio del volumen se va
aproximando mucho mejor al área debajo
de la curva esto por ser un proceso casi
estático entonces las delta y los
cambios de volumen digamos los podemos
hacer mucho más pequeños pero
eventualmente vamos a llegar a un punto
en donde si realmente suponemos cambios
infinite infinitesimalmente pequeños
verdad en esto es en términos de cálculo
lo podemos expresar como debe
entonces si tomamos una suma de todas
las presiones tenemos el área debajo de
esta curva verdad así que el en este
diagrama de presión volumen a esta
presión y esta presión que estamos
expresando con esta curva entonces
obtenemos que las matemáticas detrás de
esto nos dan que si tenemos la presión
como una función del volumen ok entonces
esencialmente esta curva de aquí la
podemos expresar como una función del
volumen es decir la presión es una
función del volumen ya hemos visto en
álgebra que en una curva es digamos ya
igual a una función de x en este caso ya
es la presión y b es nuestra x así que
el área debajo de esta curva es la
integral de la integral de la presión
como función del volumen
los pequeños cambios en el volumen
verdad las debes ahora ahora esto es por
los pequeños cambios y tomamos la suma
desde mi volumen inicial ok
hasta nuestro volumen final y vamos a
hacer esto en el futuro especialmente
para hablar de entropía pero bueno
espero que el cálculo no los confunda si
no han visto los vídeos de cálculo
pueden ignorarlo un ratito les
recomiendo que mejor lo vean
pero así expresamos el área debajo de
esta curva ahora déjenme preguntarles
algo más digamos que el trabajo está
siendo hecho por el sistema y empezamos
a agregar ahora canicas y empezamos a
agregar granitos digamos entonces vamos
en la dirección contraria vamos del
estado 2 al estado 1 y aquí la dirección
importa digamos que ahora vamos en esta
dirección vamos a poner 10 días ya estoy
encimando todo en este dibujo vamos a
hacer otra otros dibujos así que vamos a
hacer otros diagramas de presión volumen
de hecho vamos a hacer 2
22 diagramas presión volumen y hagamos
dos gráficas aquí ok
muy bien entonces en el primero iguales
presión volumen presión volumen y
empezamos en el estado 1 llegamos al
estado 2
entonces nuestro sistema esencialmente
empujo el pistón y podríamos ver una
curva o una línea de esta forma que va
en este sentido del 1 al 2 entonces en
este caso el volumen es está
incrementando así que el trabajo es el
área debajo de esta curva y como no nos
movemos hacia la derecha
pensamos que el volumen está
incrementando ahora si empezamos en el
estado 2 y vamos a la posición 1
entonces qué está ocurriendo estamos
comprimiendo verdad si vamos en esta
dirección el volumen se está reduciendo
ok
también estamos hablando del área debajo
de la curva pero va a tener un signo un
signo menos por ahí escondida así que si
hacemos esto recordemos el trabajo hecho
por el sistema de la presión por el
incremento en el volumen ahora nuestro
nuestro volumen en realidad va a ser
decreciente así que vamos en la
dirección contraria el área no es no es
otra cosa más que el área perdón el
trabajo hecho por el sistema
hecho por el sistema o más bien hacia el
sistema de verdad
ahora vamos a meter una idea más
interesante también para tener un poco
más de intuición déjenme dibujar otros
otro diagrama presión volumen muy
sencillito
ok entonces digamos que empezamos en
algún estado por aquí digamos el estado
1 y hago algo no sé en un proceso cuasi
estático de tal forma que tenemos algo
raro digamos esta curva que conecta con
el estado 2 y va en esta dirección
ok entonces mi volumen está
incrementando en esta situación cuál es
el trabajo hecho por el sistema bueno es
simplemente el área debajo de esta curva
verdad
ahora digamos que mantengo haciendo algo
no sea algún tipo de proceso cuasi
estático pero que vaya en una dirección
contraria digamos que ahora va algún
otro proceso que va del del punto 2 al 1
y toma una trayectoria así para regresar
al estado 1
muy bien entonces estas flechas van
hacia atrás ahora cuál es el trabajo
hecho al sistema bueno en mi volumen
está incrementando en la primera curva
pero en la segunda es decreciente verdad
entonces el trabajo es el área debajo de
esa curva si ahora vamos del estado 1 al
2 y luego del 2 al 1 recordemos este es
un diagrama de presión volumen bueno el
trabajo hecho por el sistema era todo el
área debajo de la curva naranja y
después ahí
teníamos el área debajo de la curva rosa
y esencialmente lo que tenemos o
restante es el área debajo o bueno que
está encerrada entre ese lazo digamos
entre entre esa curva la curva naranja
con la rosa verdad entonces desde
cálculo ya pueden tener las herramientas
para ver qué
que en realidad es el área encerrada por
estas dos curvas verdad porque la el
área debajo de la curva rosa en realidad
lleva un un signo negativo lo cual hace
que quitemos esa área verdad y entonces
primero incrementamos el volumen y luego
lo lo disminuimos por lo tanto el
trabajo del sistema es
es bastante interesante calcularlo no es
realmente el área contenida entre esas
dos curvas voy a hacer una última
observación
recuerden nuestras variables de estado
son presión y volumen hicimos varios
cambios para que al regresar para que
pudiéramos regresar al estado 1 entonces
para nuestros propósitos estamos
trabajando con gases ideales donde la
energía interna esencialmente la energía
cinética del sistema y si vamos y
hacemos cosas locas y luego regresamos
al punto inicial nuestro nuestra energía
interna no cambio así que la energía
interna siempre en este punto es la
misma es decir cuál es mi cambio en la
energía interna bueno pues esto es cero
verdad ahora sí dije que fui de 1 a 2 ok
entonces lo mejor hubo un cambio en la
energía pero como regresé al punto
inicial en realidad no tuve ningún
cambio en la energía interna y eso es
propiedad de cualquier lazo digamos que
yo pinté ok entonces si empiezo en un
punto y vuelvo al mismo entonces no tuve
no tuve cambios en la energía interna
hablaremos más de eso en el próximo
vídeo pero solo quería dejarlos con esto
la intuición detrás de las áreas debajo
de las curvas del diagrama